I've got yourself dong-ha palings do you
got a tan I like your beard I've always
wanted to select rub it a lot of
thoughts they just thought that always
comes in my house never watch your
videos on Mike do it
mmm rub it yeah that'd be weird now
never rubbed a man's beard in my life
I've done weird things trust me no [ __ ]
that's we just pass a berry together
yeah we just me damn this you anytime we
fish up in every video yeah we should
fist as much as possible I agree we have
50 we love this thing feels so good so
we're gonna watch the trailer or ah this
Jake Gyllenhaal movie called
Nightcrawler Oh is Jake Gyllenhaal yeah
is he Nightcrawler
I don't think it's the x-men character
oh good thing been talking about it
yeah how do you be very disappointed if
you saw the trailer hitch when he was in
Brooke Mountain yeah how to ride a lot
of other movies so 15 kind of related to
what we're talking yeah there is a
connection we brought a full circle
there yeah mm-hmm all right let's watch
this I don't know what the respect
appropriate so it's nothing bad
I'm looking for a job in fact I made up
my mind to find a career that I can
learn and grow into
Who am I
I'm a hard worker I set high goals and
I've been told that I'm persistent and
I'm thinking the television news might
just be something I love as well as
something I happen to be good at now I
know that today's work culture no longer
caters to the job loyalty that could be
promised to earlier generations what I
believe is that good things come to
those who work their asses off
and that good people reach the top of
the mountain didn't just fall there
my motto is if you want to win the
lottery
you have to make the money to buy a
ticket you have to make the money to buy
a ticket you have to make the money to
buy a ticket
you have to make the money to buy a
ticket oh [ __ ]
to make the money to buy a ticket
looks really cool huh looks like a fun
learning experience he's like so Phyllis
no no like so philosophical these ladies
what you gotta do is what yeah I do
he's like just telling people yeah he
could be a mentor for people some fad
that movie does look interesting I like
the way it's captured cinematography
wise because it seems like it's mainly
about the drama but when they're showing
like some action sequences those look
really cool as well so I really feel
like this director knows what he's doing
is Jake Gyllenhaal man mm-hmm [ __ ]
rocks I love that guy he's one of those
actors who used to be just okay but then
got like really good along the way
mm-hmm [ __ ] love Julie yeah he's
awesome
yeah really good after Brokeback
Mountain cuz he had to break a lot of
barrier set the one movie you know Jesus
know what nothing about him I think that
movie I don't know I boy single one time
too yeah
least I didn't seen the theaters so that
would have been an epic I saw it in the
theaters with my mom I love a very front
row in the theater so was that that was
that was an interesting experience oh I
bet it's like how do how should I look
right now
yeah do you look away if my mom sees me
will she think I'm into it what if she
looks over he's a very uncomfortable
experience yeah
yeah everything about this movie looks
pretty solid it kind of looks like it's
different though for sure it doesn't
look like your typical run-of-the-mill
kind of story yeah no it doesn't look
like oh this is gonna be easy it's just
gonna play it like this like I this
looks very intriguing I actually
wouldn't want another trailer because I
feel like it ruined too much I agree it
was good like it look like and then that
won't part someone got shot that he's
all of a sudden anchorman oh yeah it
looks like you have to [ __ ] someone over
for that one or not that's why it's a
good trailer that's why it's a good
trailer because they mislead you mm-hmm
anyway guys if you're new to the Chanel
you can subscribe here to the real
rejects and Jeremy has a channel that
he's slowly starting up he's been
telling me for weeks now it's gonna get
launched next week man next week I'm
launching the channel
and then every time some I'm about to do
it something came up
like three weeks ago I cracked seal
about left ribs so I couldn't do any
dancing or any weight lifting weight
lifting all I give stuff so now there's
better I guess start filming again
ya know he's a crazy ass dancer I'm glad
you guys have been recordings of dance
you seen at the party yeah I don't think
that's all he was not nobody is not
awake best party ever
yep yeah anyways it was a good times
good tea is a good time he hit a blast
could you tell by his face mm-hmm 9:30
let's do some show p.m. Alyssa showed up
at 10:00 and I was wide awake when
Alyssa show yeah
Oh somebody took a walk you gonna clog
it's a great time to gathered so fun I
didn't feel left out at all guys I had a
great time and then talked about it all
morning
yeah that was awesome well I had like
seven shots in a row I saw him doing
that and then he's like no but anyway
I'm like okay that's cool I had a full
margarita Murray made a very good White
Russian
mm-hm Murray can do a few good things to
you
shout out shout house of people so Jin
choy shout out from any person shout it
shout it shout it out loud all the way
from Seoul South Korea and I'm a dude
I'm going to be a freshman at UC Irvine
this September going back to Cali again
I used to live in classy San Diego for
four years during my elementary years
stay classy
I'm so happy to learn about whether you
travel to this is amazing he was his
life in a shout out he went backwards -
yeah that was really really neat so Jin
Joyce so your uh Korean nice do you do
Taekwondo because I'm stereotyping you
right now or just eat kimchi yeah
your name's like Kim sojung toy you die
say right what are you trying to say his
name
oh I thought you were saying the food
he's such an idiot as Marius
just at all shout out to you Jin Jordan
Hill and watching your videos for a
while you're great give me a shout-out
Jordan Hill you you coined that he'll
you keep going up that ladder my friend
because it's a tough road and you got to
be successful one day but the ha what
did we learn I want to win the lotto dad
buy ticket exactly I was gonna say the
thing about arrows on your back
Oh do that one do that one the higher
and mountain you climb the more arrows
are on your back
meaning haters gonna hate trying to take
you down but no man no you just keep
those arrows in the back do you bleed to
death like we United yeah fist me yeah I
got this mm good fish is a damn good
I'll just do that one again
yeah oh [ __ ] mm-hmm something about
getting fisted is just amazing yep yep
had sex with a [ __ ] Ricardo Sanchez
hey Ryan
singing kiss shouted out loud shout it
shout it shout it out loud shout it
shout it shout it out loud shout out
please
what isn't the last guy said the same
similar thing just a bunch of saying
shout out shout out repeatedly Lizzie
everybody is someone else I have like
the memory of a fish dude I don't
remember so yeah she ate about the last
is it knows before it was one of the one
but I can't talk right now
forget what I said here's your shoutout
shout out to Rick Pardo oh god you're
the man Ricardo Sanchez dude Ricardo was
the name of Lucy's husband that's what
yeah exactly
that's the only Ricardo Ricardo kind
he's like he maybe was by Richard maybe
he goes by dick dick Sanchez I wonder to
use Oh does he give dirty Sanchez's I
hope so bad is a different one
yeah that deserves a fist there yeah
this thing should do a fist count yeah
we should
it's just fits really quicker there
should be a subscriber who goes through
all of our videos together and sees how
many times were you totally in like the
accumulation of the fist fisting for
life if you one of you does that better
be awesome yeah
and is afford it stop everything you're
doing and just do that and you will get
a thank-you from us
mm-hmm someone walks in just say you're
counting how many people get fisted at
your house well I get that question all
the time because I'm usually someone
walks in when I'm looking at porn yes
you porn redtube pornhub tube 889 comm X
videos if he's ugly cheap it yeah he's a
real porn
Wow are you giving them a plug in there
yeah I'm trying to get porn of sponsor
that's okay that would be so cool we
have porn advertisements run before our
videos more people would click on those
ads I don't know about the reputation
marketing got your business people you
gotta think long-term ah sex sells right
sex does so that's why we fist
that's why we fist I think we're done
but thank you again